thank you so much i am mayor eric adams
and i'm joined here
by
members of the
fdny
ems
law enforcement
as
lights out
i'm joined as i stated by my colleagues
in government uh that are also here the
lieutenant governor
of brian benjamin uh bronx brought
president vanessa gibson
uh congressman richie torres
councilman as well fellaize
and i'm sure there's more that's here if
i miss you i apologize
uh
we are going to continue to remain
vigilant
to address this just horrific tragedy
that we're facing
of the enemy modified the numbers of
those
who
lost lives we have 17 laws
nine our adults and eight are children
uh this is a really
an evolving crisis
and so as it evolves and as we get new
information we're going to share it
with you
as well so you can let the public know
uh what we're going through we said this
yesterday and we will continue to say
uh this is an unspeakable tragedy
uh early this morning
i was joined with the chancellor
we visited uh every school
in the area where the children our young
scholars lost their lives
we sat down with the principal
and the teachers and just wanted to have
a private moment to let them know that
we are here to support them as they go
through this tragedy they shared just
personal notes
of these children it was something that
we heard universally
about each child that we lost
is
how much they smiled how much they
brought life to the school
and
not only did this fire
leave
a
burning pain
in the hearts of people in this
community
but it has
left a burning pain in the children and
the teachers and the faculties of this
school
we will support these schools in every
way
possible in the coming months
uh educators students staff
all of them
uh realize that they're going through a
traumatic moment and we want to be here
for them and it is clear that these
families
and
the entire community is receiving
support from across the country
uh just a few moments ago
i received a call from president biden
and he has made it clear that whatever
we need
uh the white house is going to be there
for us
uh he has
uh just sent a very strong message that
this is on the radar of the entire globe
of which what has happened here
of the council general of the dominican
republic is here with us
and his team uh this is a a global
tragedy because
of the bronx in new york city is
representative of the ethnicities and
cultures across the globe
and so everyone is feeling the pain of
what we are experienced but i would tell
you this and i say over and over again
we're going to get through this moment
uh we're going to get through this
moment and we're going to get through it
together
and this tragedy is not going to define
us
it is going to show our resiliency as we
help the families through this in the
middle of such pain
we have witnessed such a high level of
heroism
from the hospital staff the doctors the
nurses the administrators who are
already going through
uh crises
with the pandemic
but we also witness a high level of
heroism uh through those first
responders the ems the firefighters i
would say this over and over again
uh
watching them go in the building
um even without
uh having a full uh air tank still
pushing through the dark smoke and
rescuing families in this building
our firefighters as first responders
really showed why uh it is imperative to
give them the sport support that they
need and i want to thank commissioner
nygro for just really
leading this charge yesterday being out
here throughout the day leading his men
and women to do what was needed to save
as many families as possible and to
every grieving family 8.8 million new
yorkers see you as their family members
and we are here together to push through
this
and so some clear messages we want to
send one
for those who want to help uh please do
not drop donations off the fire stations
or ems stations let them do their jobs
they are real outlets our elected
officials are here uh you can strap them
up at the offices or
other facilities that we will put in
place if you want to do so if you want
to help financially
we have the mayor's fund to advance new
york every dollar raised will go
directly uh to the family members that
are involved so this way we can help
families in a real way
and if we take one message from this
that commissioner nigro has mentioned
several times close the door
close the door that was embedded in my
head as a child watching the commercials
over and over again we're going to
double down on that message
my conversation with the chancellor of
this morning
uh we're going to send out
communications to all of our schools and
state that we want our children to
receive the same
level
of reinforcement muscle memory is
everything and if we can drill that in
we can save lives by closing the doors
not only in the city but across the
entire globe this painful moment can
turn into a purposeful moment as we send
the right message of something simple as
closing the door
and we
i want to really thank
all the communities leaders that are
here in this community a large a member
of the african diaspora
of and recognizing uh some of the
communication gaps
break building those bridges having the
community come together as a whole
to make sure that we provide the
services that are needed uh for this
community to get get on the road of
healing from this devastating event no
one wants to hear about the loss of life
and that is even more impactful when
that loss consists of a children's of
this level in this magnitude uh before
turning it over to
uh the other representatives are here i
want to turn it over to the chancellor
who visited the schools with me today
and thank him for showing the
infrastructure support to the educators
in the school they were appreciative of
your presence and showed how serious
this matter is to all of us chancellor
of thanks
thank you mr mayor
it was certainly
my pleasure to join the mayor uh this
morning
as we visited
four schools
um two traditional public schools
and two charter schools and i think it's
important to note that
that when it comes to moments like this
there's no separation between us these
are all of our children
and to hear
the heartbreak
from the principles of each one of those
schools
the teachers
the school safety officers
the custodial workers
we came there to thank them
to let them know that we are here for
them
but they each one of them also told us
about each one of the young people who
who died
they're not just the name
they told us stories about each one of
them
and my heart broke
as we heard
just about how passionate
each young person was and how they came
to life for us
one teacher read a letter
that he had just gotten a few days ago
and it was just it was just
heartbreaking
and so
i want to say also we sent out a
i sent out a letter to
every school
uh principal
um
and educator across the city this
morning
asking that we all take time to reflect
on this tragedy
but also to make sure that we are
providing opportunities to talk about
fire safety
during this winter season there are a
lot of people in their homes in their
apartments who are using these
these heaters
and unfortunately we have these kinds of
accidents and certainly nothing as
tragic as this but this is the time to
make this
an educational moment
and as the mayor said
something as simple as closing the door
and our young people need to be taught
that they need to be reminded of that
and take that as something that they
will take with them for the rest of
their lives as well and so um i just
simply want to thank all of the
personnel
at all of our schools
um
that have been infected
the teachers the principals the
administrators the librarians the
custodians the school safety workers the
nurses
everyone has been impacted
by this it's a monumental tragedy
and uh we just send prayers
and all of our deepest thoughts with the
families who are going through so much
god bless
thank you and as indicated uh there was
a large uh gambian community here we
have the ambassador here of gambia uh um
please allow them to come up and say a
few words
thank you very much uh mayo
thank you for your leadership
i have come here from washington
to
meet the meet you and the local
authorities to learn more about this
tragic
uh
incident that took so many lives
and left many more struggling for their
lives
this is very unfortunate
and i think i dare say that the majority
of the victims apparently
have their roots from the gambia
we are a very small country
about
less than 2 million people
and we are all related everybody knows
everybody
so our country is currently in a state
of shock
before i came in here i spoke to the
president
of the republic of the gambia
and he has asked me
to extend
his condolences
to the family three family members
from the gambian from everywhere this is
a shock
our thoughts and prayers are with the
family
thank you mayor thank you thank you
we'll be here for you
so we know we want to get to the
commissioner to answer any questions but
i just want to allow those electors who
are here and was here all night for the
most part responses we want to have the
lieutenant governor brian benjamin then
the bronze vp vanessa
gibson the congressman richie torres and
then finally councilman oswell phillips
all new yorkers
share their condolences with this tragic
occurrence
and i want to just reiterate two points
uh first
governor hokel mentioned yesterday that
there will be a victims compensation
fund uh there will be resources in the
state budget uh which will be allocated
to assist on the ground and we'll work
with our local leaders to make sure that
those funds are dispersed and secondly
over 75 units in this building
which is a state supervised mitchell
llama building have project-based uh
vouchers uh individuals who are not able
to re-inhabit their apartments those
vouchers will be able to move with them
to a new uh location uh the uh uh we
will be working with the the uh the
developers and and those on the ground
to make sure that everyone has adequate
housing as soon as possible if they
cannot come back to the building and so
the state will stand with the city and
stand with the bronx to make sure that
no one is left behind and that we ensure
that everyone who's been impacted by
this tragedy gets whatever we can give
to them to make their lives whole thank
you
good afternoon
thank you so much on behalf of 1.5
million bronx sites
we extend our condolences and prayers of
healing strength
to all of those that have been impacted
by this devastating five alarm fire here
in fordham i am bronx bar president
vanessa l gibson this is my first week
on the job and i am devastated and truly
heartbroken and overwhelmed at all that
has happened in these last 24 hours
i want to thank our first responders the
fdny
commissioner daniel nigro and 200 plus
firefighters that responded in minutes
to make sure that we saved as many lives
as we could we are a mourning city and
we are a morning borough but we know
that we will survive and we will heal we
want to assure every resident and family
here at twin parks that they are not
alone
we are walking with you on this painful
journey and we're going to make sure
that we do our part and everything
necessary to provide all of the support
on the ground from the social emotional
support to making sure our children are
supported
trauma-informed care
resources temporary and long-term
housing
we have been on site since 1am to make
sure that every client had housing last
night over four hotels and all of the
residents that remain hospitalized with
serious and critical injuries so we are
asking all new yorkers and all bronx
sites to please join us in praying for
these families no one expected to wake
up on a sunday morning hearing about a
fire in their building running for their
lives this is profound sadness for all
of us but we know that in times of
challenge new yorkers step up because
that's just what we do and so we are
going to love on this community and love
on these residents and families and let
them know that they are not alone we
will walk this journey together to make
sure they have everything that is needed
i am grateful for the incredible support
from governor kathy hokel lieutenant
governor brian benjamin and all of my
colleagues in government we're going to
work together to make sure that we
prevent any tragedy from happening in
this magnitude ever again thank you so
much everyone i am so grateful and so
proud to be the borough president of a
borough like the bronx where we are
resilient we are tough and we are going
to turn our pain into purpose god bless
us all and thank you so much to all of
our first responders for your incredible
support
uh good afternoon i'm congressman richie
torres first i want to thank
the mayor who has been as visible and as
responsive and as compassionate and
comforting
as any leader as i've seen in a moment
of crisis the bronx is no stranger to
deadly fires i lived through one in
belmont just a few years ago
and so i'm enormously grateful to the
mayor to the city for mobilizing
resources
and in coming to our aid in a moment of
need you know the two things that are
most important to most of us
is our family and our homes and to lose
both in the span
of one tragedy
is terrifying and traumatic to an extent
that a few of us
could imagine what do you tell a mother
who's lost her children and who's lost
her home who's lost everything who's
seen
the world around her collapsed so we're
going to do our best to bring comfort to
those families
i do want to tell the mayor and the city
that
as a local congressman i'm committed to
advancing legislation
that addresses either the manufacturing
of space heaters or the need for
education about fire safety or the need
for self-closing doors and affordable
housing that receives federal funding so
you have a partner at the federal level
thank you
thank you so much everyone i'm
councilmember felice i represent uh this
area of the bronx
what happened yesterday was a
frightening nightmare
the bronx continues to have many
challenges and fire continues to be one
of them we've had some of the worst
fires in the city of new york right here
in the bronx including the belmont fire
including the one in woody crest
including the one yesterday where we
lost 19 lives including
babies four-year-olds
but i want to thank all of our wonderful
leaders our colleagues in government
cities
state and federal who have been here
around the clock and available and
providing all the resources needed to
all the affected families including food
including clothing and including housing
and as council member i'll be working
with my colleagues including our
congressman at the federal level our
borough president our mayor eric adams
and our state elected leaders
to make sure that we get additional
fire related laws to protect new yorkers
because we've had far too many fires and
this cannot continue to be the future of
our borough so we're going to be
continuing to work with our leaders to
make sure we strengthen some of our laws
analyze what exactly happened yesterday
and what we could learn from it and what
we can do to make sure it never happens
again thank you so much um for being
here thank you thank you i'm going to
bring on uh the uh the commissioner fire
commissioner uh nigro and
uh the deputy commissioner of oem for
there's any uh updates on what we're
doing and as we mobilize to move forward
thank you mayor the investigation
continues as i said yesterday were we're
certain that the fire started with a
faulty electrical
heater portable heater
the fire
was contained to the hallway just
outside this two-story apartment but the
smoke
traveled throughout the building and the
smoke is what caused the deaths and the
serious injuries
so our fire marshals teams are here
they've been here
they've been examining the building
they've been examining videotape they
will do a complete investigation as to
as to how this uh how this occurred why
this occurred and we're confident
of that as the mayor stated previously
uh patients were taken to seven
different hospitals there was a a bit of
a double count
and uh i guess it's a bit of good news
that the number isn't 19 but 17 but
don't forget there are many people
fighting for their lives in the hospital
who are transported so this number
could unfortunately uh increase again so
our prayers are with them and the
prayers
continue to be with the families of
those we lost
uh i will let oem discuss
more about the continued operations for
the families
thank you
uh so last night the building was
totally vacated uh no apartments were
habited last night we threw the american
red cross with housing preservation and
development and with the building
management about uh half of those units
so about 60 different families stayed in
area hotels we were able to house
everyone in the bronx
um and the rest as they said there are
people still in hospitals and people
also went to friends and family
ongoing is um
registration with the red cross people
are still people coming out of hospitals
people who are at work or somewhere else
so it's never too late people can
continue to register with the red cross
we worked with the department of
education they were able to help to get
the children back as was noted back to
their schools this morning
um and they will continue to help them
until people are back in the building uh
it does look like many of the apartments
will be able to be reoccupied as the
week goes on which is good news uh there
are a certain number of apartments that
will be um you know not habitable for
quite some time and so we will continue
to work to find long-term housing with
the state and with the city
we moved out of the school since the
school opened this morning there is now
a service center at monroe college which
is close by we have several different
agencies there it opened at 12 o'clock
it's open until 8 pm it'll be open this
week
so residents can come by there and
continue to receive services we have
interpreters there there has been an
outpouring of support as everyone said
the borough president everyone else
there's a lot of food and other
resources that we have been able to
share with the families thank you
a couple questions guys starting in
front
to the mayor and to the commissioner
of the people who died
and of the people who suffered critical
injuries
were they all found in the hallways and
the stairwells or were some of them
actually found in their apartments the
reason i asked is i wonder whether those
victims would have been better off had
they remained in their apartment and
waited for firefighters to rescue
okay uh i don't have a tally of where
exactly everyone was found the people
from the fire department all got out on
their own
and they are they were safe certainly
the stairwell
was very dangerous as the door was left
open uh some of the floors
certainly on 15 the door was open from
the stair to the hall and the 15th floor
became quite untenable
we do recommend in high-rise fireproof
buildings that people should shelter in
place and it's safer to be in your
apartment than to venture out and try to
get down the stairs and sometimes into a
much more dangerous situation
but this investigation as i said before
it's incomplete and inconclusive so far
so is there a reason why those doors
aren't self-closing
they are self-closing but the door on 15
and the door to the fire department was
not functioning as it should
well it would be if it was pointed out
so we'd like to point out today to
everyone if you're in a building an
apartment building that has self-closing
doors make sure it works and if it
doesn't please point that out to the
landlord to the maintenance folks and
make sure your door closes as it should
it's still part of the investigation
there has been some stories that the
alarm system went off uh regularly
there's been some stories that people
smoking in the halls set off the alarm
so
our investigation will determine
been owned by that couple of different
people in the last few years
who have oversight of this building is
it state authorities or is it uh
i can answer the first question the door
was not obstructed the door when it was
fully open stayed fully open because it
malfunctioned as far as the building
ownership uh someone else would have to
answer that
it's all of the above so it's
project-based section 8 which is a
federal program
it is a statement your llama which is
the state and every property regardless
of whether it's federal state is subject
to the building housing and fire code
yes
commissioner were there smoke detectors
in the hallways are they required in the
hallways as well and or should they be
smoking the smoke alarms are required in
the apartments there were smoke alarms
sounding as i said yesterday the first
call from a neighbor came because they
heard smoke alarms sounding in the
building uh the people the folks in the
apartment where the fire started were
alerted by the fire itself
so
that didn't seem to be a factor in this
fire what about in hallways are they
required this is a very long building
would that have helped if they were in
hallways
i don't know if that would have helped
or if they were required in this
particular building
they opened the door to escape the
apartment there were multiple people
living in that apartment as they left
they opened the door and the door stayed
opened two more guys right there
is there any investigation as to whether
or not the residents were receiving
adequate feet
we're going to lift up all this if i
want to go back to the resident in the
open apartment and we want to be clear
here
that we don't want to add further trauma
on that family
because they fled the apartment
you know muscle memory during the crisis
you're trying to get out
it is our obligation to reinforce the
concept of close the door close the door
but what we don't want to do is just to
add more trauma on the family that was
simply trying to escape a very dangerous
and a very frightening experience
of all of us
make mistakes during crises
and so yes we want to encourage we're
going to double down on closing the door
and that message
is our obligation to do so but our
hearts go out to this family and i just
want to be clear on that they're going
through trauma uh as as well
there was no outstanding violations of
our knowledge of the heat complaint in
the building
but again that investigation is really
new and the
fire marshal and other city entities are
looking at all of this information
um be expected to be completed and what
is the building managers and what are
they doing to exactly help with the
investigation
well they have to comply
and the investigation will be completed
when the fire marshal do their thorough
look we have a professional fire marshal
uh entity in this city and one thing we
never want to do is to try to make an
investigation be expeditious but not
thorough they're going to be thorough
they do their job well and they would
give the outcome and they know when it
would be completed
that's it thanks a lot guys
thank you